an unknown Alliance a secret Fu and a
damning hint towards the future their
secrets Stitch into these sci-fi threads
so which one plays homage to detectives
and suffragettes
will Wheaton's Wesley Crusher made his
Star Trek debut in an episode of The
Next Generation in 1987. the son of Dr
Beverly Crusher he's long been one of
the fandom's most divisive characters
some found him annoying others found his
Super Genius skills Preposterous and the
rest just didn't like the idea of a
teenager on the bridge of the Enterprise
nevertheless Crusher received the
provisional rank of acting instant in
the episode where no one has gone before
along with his own special uniform at
dance and Wesley crusher's costume in
awkward great toned turtleneck with the
rainbow stripe that wraps around the
shoulders set him apart from the rest of
the crew it also held a secret message
the colorful stripe across his chest is
made up of all three divisional colors
worn by the rest of the crew red
represents the command division yellow
is for security and operations and blue
is for Science and medical Crusher wears
all three to denote that as a
provisional officer he hasn't yet chosen
a division
Jody Whitaker's 13th Doctor on Doctor
Who faced sexist backlash following her
Casting but Theo found fault with her
colorful offbeat outfit Whitaker first
appeared in a blue shirt with a rainbow
stripe a long gray coat and suspenders
holding up a pair of blue trousers which
gave the 13th Doctor the right mix of
style and quirkiness but wild fans
noticed subtle homages to the past the
Fourth Doctor's colorful stripes the
11th Doctor's bow ties and the
high-waisted pants of the second doctor
there's more for example the blue and
gray represent the sky in space in a
behind the scenes featurette Whittaker
pointed to her earrings saying and then
there's a whole journey of stars and
hands in the earring and the chain is
the journey and the rose gold hand is
humanity costume designer Ray Holman
added a violet lining to her coat
sleeves because it was one of the colors
of the suffragettes the activists who
fought for women's votes in the United
Kingdom for Whitaker it was important
that her costume not be overly feminine
or masculine she explained the main
journey of it came from a photograph
that I found if a woman in trousers
braces and a t-shirt walk in with
purpose Whittaker loved its Intrigue and
timelessness in the 13th Doctor style
was born a genre breaking superhero
movie that shattered long-held Hollywood
perceptions black panther saw the late
Chadwick Boseman lead the people of
wakanda to glory wakanda is home to a
Rare Element called vibranium which
allows the country to develop futuristic
technology while still honoring the
people's culture and traditions costume
designer Ruthie Carter created many of
the futuristic outfits seen in the film
to pay homage to Africa's past inspired
by the style called afrofuturism Carter
created some 700 unique costumes for the
movie including ceremonial dress and the
warrior armor worn by the likes of Okoye
we crafted a costume that really did did
represent all the areas of Africa for
example Carter Incorporated beadwork
from the turkana tribe and leather
skirts wrapped the way the women of the
himba tribe dress in an interview with
NPR she explained I really wanted this
to have a feeling that if you were an
aspiring Dora milage if you were
training and you were granted the
position to be a member that you would
be presented with this honor in this
beautiful uniform it's a great honor for
someone to be a Dora milaje they also
wear neck rings and arm rings that are
from South Africa for the 2022 sequel
wakanda forever Carter designed another
2 000 outfits including the Midnight
Angel armor worn by akoye using the
original comic book art as a starting
point real African designs were added
she told Entertainment Weekly we landed
on a mask style it's very much like the
mask of the Benin or South Africa where
you see the slanted eye with a round
shape the Back to the Future Trilogy
didn't require much elaborate costuming
the first and third films are set in the
past but 1989's Back to the Future Part
2 plays out in the far a future of 2015.
oddly enough though it's not the Slick
futuristic fashion worn by Marty McFly
or the cyberpunk costumes of bifton and
in his cronies that hides some hidden
meaning instead it's the more ordinary
attire of scientist Doc Brown throughout
the film Brown wears a bright Loosely
fitted button-down shirt but look
closely and you'll see the shirt doesn't
feature the Hawaiian flowers you might
expect but a repeating pattern depicting
a steam locomotive it's no coincidence
of course that in the third and final
film in the series Marty and Doc Brown
hijacked just such a train to carry them
back to the future later Brown even uses
a locomotive as a time machine and here
it was a year earlier being foreshadowed
in his shirt but that's not all pay
close attention to the train hijacking
scene in Back to the Future Part 3 and
you'll see that Doc uses the same shirt
torn up as his face covering while
playing a gun-toting bandit
a mind-bending Sci-Fi Journey Through
the wild west at least at first
Westworld is peppered with clues for the
audience viewers pour over every scene
hunting for details that may hold some
significance and the cast elaborate
costumes are always a good place to
start the architecture guy did the
costumes so there's this lack of detail
to most of our costumes that's
intentional while costume designer shade
kunliff insists that many of the
clothing decisions weren't as deliberate
as some fans believe they were
absolutely influenced by the story's
deeper themes but there is at least one
choice that hit a deeper meaning in
season 3 when Dolores Returns the many
blue outfits are a nod to the iconic
blue dress she wore inside the park in
the first two seasons also when
Clementine returns now in the outside
world her post-modern dress matches her
flowing gown from inside the Westworld
Park in an interview with Insider
kunleth referred to such callbacks as
part of a theme song of color that ran
throughout the series
based on the seminal novel by Margaret
Atwood the handmade stale takes place in
a grim near future in which the United
States has become an authoritarian
Society women are a subjugated lower
class and Bland robes and bonnet-like
head coverings that are color-coded
based on their role in society handmaids
wear blood red wives wear royal blue
domestic workers wear green and so on
the outfits are designed to show the
woman's complete lack of power costume
designer and Crabtree told Vanity Fair
it was kind of Twisted to think about
how I would hinder women their body
shape and also their movement and their
freedom with the clothing I had to do it
to make it realistic but also to help
the actors you feel blinkered completely
blinkered she went on to explain that
she took a psychological approach to the
color-coded system saying there's less
and less power as you go down the color
spectrum except with the color red that
is by Design from the book her job was
to create outfits designed by oppressors
though she admitted she had a couple of
things in the designs that were meant to
be an Fu to the men keeping these women
down she confessed I did an inverted
female vagina in the design of the
aunt's collars if you look subtly you'll
see that it's no coincidence that the
costumes worn by the authoritarian
Terran Federation and Starship Troopers
recall those warned by heimranking Nazi
officers during World War II over the
years director Paul verhoven has spoken
about how the film which is based on the
Robert a Heinlein novel of the same name
is a satire of military dictatorships
like the Third Reich for example Carl
Jenkins played by a young Neil Patrick
Harris wears a uniform that starkly
invokes the Gestapo Adolf Hitler's
secret police rather than glorifying
authoritarianism as many critics wrongly
assumed upon the film's release the
uniforms were meant to be a subtle
takedown of the frightening ways
authoritarian regimes justify their
brutality spiroven told Entertainment
Weekly what I tried to do is use
subversive imagery to make a point about
Society I tried to seduce the audience
to join the movie Society but then ask
what are you really joining up for
1999's the Matrix may be one of the most
analyzed sci-fi films ever made from the
film's trans allegory to its prescient
look at a future ruled by data and
consumerism every detail of the film has
been poured over since its release and
the costume of arguably the film's most
important character the Oracle has an
escaped notice depicted as an older
motherly woman the Oracle can see Neo's
future you're the Oracle bingo
she appears in an ordinary Suburban
kitchen dressed in a green blouse and an
orange apron but this simple costume
actually mirrors the work of Renaissance
Master Michelangelo the outfit recalls
the delphic Civil who appears in
Michelangelo's most celebrated work the
ceiling of the Sistine Chapel the
delphic Sybil is a Seer one of the most
powerful prophets in the ancient world
according to Legend she even predicted
the Trojan War Ridley Scott's Blade
Runner based on Philip K Dick's novel to
Android's Dream of Electric Sheep is a
cyberpunk sci-fi movie about a
government agent who hunts down Rogue
Androids everything from the dialogue in
the sets to the use of color and
lighting is meant to pay homage to Old
detective movies including Rick
deckard's look which is influenced by
movies of that era in a chat with
another magazine costume Designer
Michael Kaplan explained we definitely
felt that Blade Runners of that film
Noir genre and we looked back to the
films of the 1940s for inspiration
Deckard was as much a gumshoe as the
Maltese Falcon Sam Spade in fact
deckard's costume is an obvious tip of
the cap to the iconic detective a sort
of futuristic Spade the 20 2017 sequel
Blade Runner 2049 took a different route
it's set 30 years later and the world is
an even worse place so the Wardrobe had
to reflect that the clothing in the
second film is tougher more durable
bulkier and uglier the fashion is like
very expressive but linked with
surviving and all they will incorporate
survival gears in those clothes and
making them like fashion statements
designer Renee April told indiewire I
didn't want costumes with lots of
zippers and plastic so my job was to
make the characters believable 2021's
Dune is a sweeping outer space Saga
where rival houses battle for control of
a vast Interstellar Empire based on the
Frank Herbert novel of the same name
Dune calls for futuristic battle suits
and outfits that can withstand the
environments and harsh alien worlds but
also formal attire for the powerful
House of Trades the architecture of the
film is drawn from a school of design
called brutalism and some of the outfits
have a similar origin for me I wanted
the custom design to feel like a
historical movie to move away from
fantasy in the 2021 Interview With The
Hollywood Reporter costume designer
Jacqueline West discussed the source of
inspiration saying you want it simple
stripped down utilitarian I approached
nearly all of the costumes that way I
never wanted anything to look
overreaching or overdone and Baroque in
any way west took cues from the Romanov
family the last Dynasty to rule Russia
before the Revolution explaining I
thought their costumes were quite
elegant yet simple why the romanovs
though it's quite simple as Wes
explained to The Hollywood Reporter I
thought they were a doomed family just
like the house of atreyotes where
everything was about to be taken away
from them I thought there would be some
symbolism for the audience to see and
feel that maybe they would make that
connection even subliminally
foreign